razionalità
autenticità e scintilla
l'estrema razionalità A volte può essere
in contrapposizione con l'essere
autentici
autenticità è mostrare la nostra vera
interiorità al di là di quello che
vogliamo apparire o che crediamo di
essere
nell'autenticità dimora una scintilla e
ogni scintilla scocca grazie a un evento
che la fa brillare se pensiamo la
scintilla più grande pensiamo al Big
Bang la scintilla che ha creato il
nostro mondo
immaginiamo l'origine del tutto il vuoto
cosmico il buio e poi d'improvviso la
luce
Ognuno di noi ha in sé una propria
scintilla di autenticità la storia della
mia scintilla ve la racconto attraverso
una mia personalissima interpretazione
di una delle opere più conosciute al
mondo
La Primavera del Botticelli che narra di
una rinascita così come accade ad ognuno
di noi dopo un periodo difficile ma
partiamo dall'inizio Come ogni storia
che si rispetti anche la mia inizia con
C'era una volta C'era una volta una
bambina di 5 anni in un paesino nei
dintorni di Milano con una copertina di
Linus sempre con sé un astuccio pieno di
matite colorate e il fiato un po' corto
come tutte le bimbe di quell'età vivevo
in un mondo giocoso e sognante avevo due
grandi cose
un'immaginazione prorompente e l'asma
in compagnia dell'asma la mia infanzia
era scandita da lunghe e noiose giornate
solitarie che però lasciavano grande
spazio alla mia fantasia di bambina
sognante quel mondo lo chiamavo la mia
bolla era popolato da diverse creature
dalle sembianze oniriche gentili e
coloratissime che presto divennero i
miei amici immaginari poi sono guarita
dall'asma e mentre tutti i miei amici
perdevano il loro amico immaginario Io
ce l'ho sempre con me lo vedete sono
guarita dall'asma ma non sono mai
guarita dall'immaginazione
Avete presente quei luoghi che tendiamo
a tenere nascosti per noi
quelle attività che ci Rilassano dai
ognuno di noi ne ha uno ecco quella
bolla fanciullesca rimase per me per
anni in un posto prezioso e intimo e
solo recentemente ho scoperto quanto
questa mia passione per dipingere possa
essere anche importante per la mia
carriera lavorativa
Il mio amico non poteva rimanere da solo
e così ho iniziato a disegnarlo e
quaderno Dopo quaderno sono nati anche
tutti gli altri amici immaginari
come tutti i neolaureati Anch'io ho
fatto un sacco di Gavetta sempre
studiato lavorato un sacco di fatica poi
nel 2016 la svolta mi chiama una
multinazionale americana per ricoprire
la posizione di General manager mi
affidano un team di tante persone e la
responsabilità di milioni e milioni di
fatturato
immaginatevi come mi potessi sentire in
quel momento A dire il vero un po' come
mi sento io oggi qui a parlare davanti a
voi
l'azienda aveva grandi aspettative il
fatturato doveva crescere una sfida
importante così come nella primavera del
Botticelli Zefiro il vento di primavera
in segue la Ninfa Clori della quale è
innamorato anche io inseguivo le mie
passioni i numeri sono sempre stata
affascinata e appassionata di numeri
talmente ossessionata che avevo
raggiunto tutti i risultati di vendita e
anche superati e tutti i miei
collaboratori avevano preso il bonus la
descrizione della manager perfetta non
pensate anche voi così
poi esce il tanto atteso sondaggio
aziendale sul gradimento dei dipendenti
mi ricordo in particolare due domande la
prima il vostro capo si prende cura di
voi come persone
la seconda le vostre opinioni contano
Non vedevo l'ora di vedere il risultato
era la mia prova del nove
esco di risultati vado nell'ufficio di
Serena che la responsabile delle risorse
umane mi mostra un foglio con la media
dei risultati da 0 a 5 Secondo voi
quanto posso aver preso
5 ovviamente guardo il 5 faccio un bel
sorriso Serena mi guarda e mi dice Ma ti
rendi conto riguardo il foglio quel 5
era un due
ero talmente convinta di aver preso il
massimo dei voti che avevo letto il
foglio al contrario
così Il mio team mi aveva bocciata come
leader e io non ero per niente
consapevole
e dire che pensavo che i numeri fossero
tutto
così Cosa faccio decido di fare e
adottare ciò che ho sempre desiderato al
mondo Adotto un gattino amo da pazzi gli
animali e ho iniziato così a prendermi
cura anche un po' di me stessa al di
fuori del lavoro però dopo poco tempo
sarà stato il pelo del gatto Sarà stata
la delusione per il sondaggio si
ripresenta l'asma mi sono dovuta
allontanare dal mio adorato gattino e
prendere un periodo di convalescenza dal
lavoro
in quel periodo di estrema solitudine e
fragilità mi rifugio nella mia bolla da
bambina
mi ritorna prepotente l'immaginazione e
mi lascio andare senza limiti alla
fantasia e alla creatività
accettando e riconoscendo quella mia
parte più intima ed emozionale
dai miei quaderni sono nati poi
barababble se hanno iniziato a Popolare
grandi tele fatte ad acquerello ho dato
loro anche un nome e un carattere per
renderli ancora più intimi e personali
tutti noi ci possiamo riconoscere in
ognuno di loro per esempio Barabba
è il nome del personaggio che più mi
rappresenta forte e impaziente
boda empatico e relazionale
Oco socievole creativo fino a
preciso e razionale
Loro sono i barababbles e nascono dalla
mia bolla da bambina
così tornata al lavoro avevo capito
tante cose capito quanto la razionalità
poteva convivere in armonia anche con le
emozioni grazie al mio team ho capito
l'importanza di tante cose ho portato
con autenticità anche la mia arte sul
lavoro
Ho iniziato a comprendere a capire il
bisogno del mio team a volergli bene e
anche i barababble stanno iniziando a
lanciare Grandi Scuole per far vedere il
loro lato gentile
tutti noi proviamo emozioni e
diciamocelo ci piace anche tanto ma sul
lavoro tendiamo a reprimerle pensando
che siano in contrapposizione con la
professionalità o con la carriera invece
per me Mostrare i barababables la mia
arte e le mie emozioni al mio team ha
permesso la creazione di fiducia un
ambiente armonioso e creativo dove
l'errore non esiste i barababbox ci
hanno aiutato ad abbassare le gerarchie
a conoscerci meglio e a sostituire
l'idea di errore con il concetto di idea
propulsiva incrementale che rimanda
l'idea del viaggio della sperimentazione
dell' errare
sospendendo il giudizio
così come nella primavera del Botticelli
è nata Flora per il Botticelli La
Primavera La rinascita impersonata da
Barabba la nuova Isabella ho capito
proprio che questa unione mi metteva
molto di più in bilanciamento
razionalità emozioni lavoro vita privata
la Venere al centro del dipinto
rappresenta ognuno di noi nel nostro
momento di pace di equilibrio quel senso
di completezza
e poi fino a lui Ve lo ricordate quello
laggiù in fondo lui è il preciso e
mercurio interpreta Mercurio che cerca
di scacciare tutte le nuvole perché
vuole mantenere una primavera perfetta
ma si sa i temporali arrivano
inaspettati e allora proviamo a fare un
po' come Mercurio a tenere lontane le
lume dell'estrema razionalità facciamo
scoccare la nostra scintilla e
portiamola con autenticità in giro per
il mondo
Un'ultima cosa Il mio gattino sta
benissimo e lo vado a trovare ogni tanto
dalla mia cara amica Ciao a tutti da
Barbara Bubbles
[Applauso]